>> Mark: CHINA IS SUPPOSEDLY
MODERNIZING AND BECOMING A
GLOBAL SUPERPOWER, BUT IN OTHER
WAYS IT STILL REMAINS A
SERIOUSLY MEDIEVAL.
HEALTH OFFICIALS THERE HAVE JUST
CONFIRMED THE FOURTH INCIDENT
THIS MONTH OF PLAGUE.
AS IN THE PLAGUE.
THE PLAGUE THAT KILLED HALF OF
EUROPE IN THE MIDDLE AGES.
HOW THE PLAGUE SPREAD AND IS IT
HEADING HERE?
DR. MARC SIEGEL IS A FOX MEDICAL
CONTRIBUTOR AND HE JOINS US NOW.
WE ARE LAUGHING ABOUT IT, BUT
THE THREE BIG PANDEMICS OF THE
PLAGUE SINCE THE 14TH CENTURY
HAVE ALL COME FROM THIS PART OF
THE WORLD.
>> AND THE REASON FOR THAT, WE
ARE NOT REALLY LAUGHING ABOUT
THIS PART, THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT, EVEN THOUGH THEY'VE
CREATED A CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL THAT IS PATTERNED AFTER
OUR OWN, WHERE THEY LITERALLY
TRACK CASES AND THEY KNOW WHO IS
SICK, THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
INFORM THE WORLD ABOUT THIS.
THEY SUPPRESS IT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, THEY DELETE THE
TWEETS WHERE THEY SAY, HEY,
SOMEONE HAS THE PLAGUE.
THEY DON'T TELL THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION FOR WEEKS.
AS YOU ARE MENTIONING, THIS LED
TO AN OUTBREAK OF A VIRUS CALLED
SARS IN 2003 THAT SPREAD TO OVER
30 COUNTRIES.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THAT HAPPENING
WITH THE PLAGUE.
THEY HAVE CHECKPOINTS ON THE
ROADS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE THEY ARE DRIVING
YOU ALONG THE ROAD AND THEY ARE
STOPPING YOU TO CHECK IF YOU
HAVE THE PLAGUE?
ARE YOU ARE AT THE AIRPORT AND
THEY ARE CHECKING YOUR
TEMPERATURE QUESTION MARKET IS
SPREADING PANIC IN CHINA RIGHT
NOW
>> Mark: ISN'T THIS SOMETHING
TO DO WITH THEIR SO-CALLED, 100,
TWO SYSTEMS THING.
AS WITH SARS, AND PRESUMABLY IT
COULD HAPPEN WITH THE PLAGUE,
SOME GUY AND RULE CHINA EATS THE
WRONG THING AND THEN HER AUNT
GOES TO VISIT HER COUNTRY IN
HONG KONG IN ONE OF THEM HAPPENS
TO BE STANDING AT THE ELEVATOR
OF THE INTERCONTINENTAL AND THE
BUSINESSMAN STAYING THERE IT
GETS ON A FLIGHT TO CAPE TOWN OR
NEW YORK OR PARIS AND THAT'S HOW
IT SPREADS.
>> EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU COULD BE WORKING FOR THE
CDC.
LET ME TELL YOU, IT'S A BACTERIA
AND IT LIVES IN RODENTS.
IN RODENTS AROUND THE WORLD
STILL CARRY THIS BACTERIA BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IN PARTS OF CHINA,
THEY ARE EATING IT RAW.
ALSO FLEAS ON THE SURFACE OF
THESE VARMINTS THEN SPREAD IT TO
HUMANS.
FLEAS HOPPING FROM RATS TO
THAT IS WHY IT WAS SO DEADLY IN
EUROPE BECAUSE THEY HAD A
PROBLEM WITH ALL THE RATS.
OF THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT RIGHT
NOW IS TRYING TO KILL ALL THE
RODENTS AND THE FLEAS AND THEY
ARE TRYING TO CONTROL IT THAT
WAY, WHICH IS PROBABLY A GOOD
IDEA BUT THE FEAR WORRIES ME
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU GET THE PLAGUE IF IT IS
ENTREATED FAST ENOUGH WITH
ANTIBIOTICS QUESTION MARKET
DEVELOPS A LONG FORM.
THEN THE PLAGUE COULD BE SPREAD
BY LITERALLY COUGHING ONTO
SOMEBODY.
>> Mark: AND HAS A MUCH HIGHER
DEATH RATE.
>> TWO OF THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
HAD IT THIS MONTH, THIS VERSION,
IF THEY GOT ON A PLAN GOD FORBID
CAME TO NEW YORK, YOU COULD SEE
A CASE HERE.
>> Mark: BEFORE ANYONE
INVENTED AIR TRAVEL, AND THE
19TH CENTURY, THE LAST BIG
PANDEMICS STARTED KILLING
MEMBERS OF THE CHINESE COMMUNITY
IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
CHESTER ARTHUR SIGNED THE
CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT, WHICH
EVERYONE THINKS HE DID BECAUSE
HE WAS A BIG, HORRIBLE, WHITE
RACIST BUT IN FACT IT WAS A
HEALTH ISSUE.
YOU GET THE FEELING THAT THAT
WOULD NOT BE POLITICALLY
FEASIBLE AT ALL TODAY.
ARE WE SUPPOSED TO TRUST CHANCE
THAT NOBODY GETS ON THAT PLANE
CUSTOMER >> NO, WE NEED TO BE
FIGHTING THIS POINT, JUST LIKE
WE ARE DOING ON THE SHOW HERE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ONE SOCIETY
VERSUS ANOTHER OR THE COLOR OF
YOUR SKIN, IT'S ABOUT THE RISK
TO PUBLIC HEALTH AND WHEN YOU
SEE A DISEASE REEMERGING.
EVEN MORE THAN FOUR CASES A
MONTH AND WE WILL SEE A LOT MORE
CASES, WE NEED TO GET THE
INFORMATION OUT THERE.
IT NEEDS TO BE AT AIRPORTS AND
PEOPLE NEED TO BE ON THE
LOOKOUT.
FEAR SPREADS MORE DISEASE THAN
ANY VIRUS OR ANY BACTERIA.